when i first started bringing my kids in
the woods i wasn't sure how they take to
it and it seems like it's in their blood
it makes me feel real proud
let's go check out the bath house we got
some work to do ahead of us
part of having these hot springs is
taking care of the hot springs there's a
cold stream that flows next to the bath
house what we're gonna do is start
working to get this whole place cleaned
out take all the mud out and hopefully
come away with a beautiful bathtub what
we want to do
is take these rocks out here
and kind of divert the stream going in
we're just getting all this water to
flow through and then it'll take all the
mud with it yeah well not all this mud
but inside we could stir it up and get
that mud and stuff that's in there on
the pallet washed out
okay let's go inside
put on some rubber boots
i want to teach skyler a little bit of
like community service a lot of us use
these hot springs a lot of us use his
bath house and fixing this bath house is
teaching him how to be a better person
when he comes to an area he leaves it a
better place
let's see that bucket i could fill it up
with mud you can just carry it out
last time this is done is probably years
so
the mud's really built
up okay
well let's keep taking loads of mud out
of here what we want is a sand bottom
not a mud bottom
get all this mud up very dark black mud
comes from deep within the earth
and it basically just settles inside of
that bathtub what i'm trying to do is
take a good six to eight inches of mud
off the bottom of this bathtub so it
gets the clean clear water inside life's
too short for a muddy bath
it's getting down to the sand though
skye you are yeah
we are
you're doing a lot of work
skylar is working his butt off he's
taking these pans of mud and dumping
them outside and they're ready to be
filled up again
working together like this we get a lot
of work done
okay
oh that one's happy
okay skye looks like we're about done in
here we got it down to sand all the
mud's out
good job on carrying all that dirt out
with skyler's help we were able to clean
that entryway out completely of mud and
it's looking beautiful now it looks good
you want to close that stream off out
there real quick yeah okay i'm gonna dry
off shut that cold water down we're done
with it
people at home in the city they're using
the cold knob and the hot knob on the
faucet to get that perfect temperature
that's what me and skylar are doing
today but we're using a creek and a hot
springs to work out a perfect
temperature in this bath house i'm gonna
really block this off right here
it should be good
my job in the hot tub
is complete
[Music]
you